لقد اجتمعنا معًا لإنجاز مهمة
سنقوم بالتجول حولها ، ونريد أن
نظهر للعالم أنه مع
الرعاية المناسبة للأطراف الصناعية وكيفية العناية بها ، فإنها
تحدث فرقًا كبيرًا في حياة شخص ما
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي كينيث ، قصة فقدت ساقي
في عام 2010 في الخارج في أفغانستان
ومع مشاة البحرية الأمريكية بعد
إصابتي ، شعرت بالضياع والحيرة في الكثير من
الأسئلة حول لماذا ما زلت على قيد الحياة
لماذا أنا هنا
الأفكار الانتحارية التي جعلت الاستيقاظ
كل يوم أمرًا صعبًا للغاية
بالنسبة لي فقط.  أصبحت علاجي ، وجدت
نفسي ألهم الآخرين وأحفز
الآخرين على أن يكونوا نشيطين ، كما
أننا حاليًا في الإكوادور نتسلق
نطاقًا من مشروع الحركة وهي منظمة محلية
توفر
الهواء الاصطناعي وتقويم العظام للبلدان التي ليس لديها
وسيلة لتوفير مثل هذا  رعاية
مواطنيهم ، لدينا 10 إلى 12 مبتورًا
يتسلقون بركان I Amba ، كلنا نأتي من
خلفيات مختلفة وجميع
الإصابات المختلفة لكوني جزءًا من هذا الفريق بالنسبة
لي أمر مهم للغاية  النملة وهو
مصدر إلهام لشخص ما ، سيستغرق خليج كايين من
الملجأ حوالي 12 ساعة ،
لدينا المعدات والعتاد ولكن
علينا التحلي بالصبر وانتظار
الطقس المناسب للوصول إلى القمة بأمان
سواء كنا بعض كايين بالبركان أم
لا  هو مجرد جزء صغير مما
نحن هنا من أجله ولكن هذا التسلق آمل
أن يتعلم الآخرون الكثير عن
أنفسهم وقدراتهم
يمكنهم فعل أي شيء يريدونه فلا
يوجد شيء مستحيل
[موسيقى]